listening to a film courage women
and Karen Warren I'm late offering you
yeah but you know the thing is I think
we also were thinking are we really
gonna wait 12 months to submit like
we're gonna forego every other film
festival for 20 months just to have the
chance to submit a better version this
movie I felt like we made a decision
that like let's just throw it to
Sundance and see what happens I am I
have friends who have made movies and
we'll wait 10 months to submit because
they they're like I'm waiting for
Sundance next year because that's and
then they submit they don't get it and
then they're like I just wasted 10
months of my life and it's like the
worst thing and and the whole idea of
premier status because that's big
because you know I have a friend who's a
program of a festival and I asked him
you know how important is premier status
and he said it's pretty important
honestly because festival programmers
want to make sure that they can get
industry types industry folks to like
Todd's agent like my agent to come to
the festival in order to do that these
industry types need to feel like they're
the first person to ever see this movie
so you need to be a world premiere and
you can only have your world premiere
once so you know he said the festival he
runs he he'll do the third world
premieres a third American premieres and
then a third whatever else so you really
need to think about and it's the dumbest
thing ever but you really anything about
where are we going to world premiere
because you'd only need to do it once
right